this is a thursday at San Manuel Stadium
east of Los Angeles and Harley
Morenstein is getting ready to shoot the
latest episode of his TV show Epic Meal
Empire before Epic Meal Empire there was
epic Meal Time a YouTube show which made
Morenstein an internet sensation I
wouldn't call Epic Meal Time a cooking
show I would call it a celebration of
food show epicMealTime was an internet
show that I made four years ago in my
backyard the first video got 120,000
views in a week we did one right away
the next week it got 600,000 views at
that point I was like all right I put my
job as a teacher and just committed to
making the videos weekly now it's four
years later we have 700 million views
with that kind of viewership
epicMealTime had big media companies
looking to cash in on the success Kings
this cooking game epic meal time first
pops we started getting phone calls from
Hollywood discovery revision3 here book
maker studios they all wanted to
represent epic meal time we'd work with
collective already so we we just had
faith in them collective digital studio
produces and promotes YouTube channels
epicMealTime was already established
before we got more mean you got very
aggressive about trying to get into
business with them because our vision
was always that this is the kind of
property that is multi-platform it's
really strong frat humor Reza is I'd
sees a new world where stars are self
generating audiences online we're at a
place where now the mainstream world is
starting to realize that maybe they're
not as mainstream as they think that the
mainstream may be actually sitting in
the halls of YouTube and what collective
can help do
is take a show like epic meal time from
a backyard to the mainstream media we
have the TV property they have a number
of brands that they've had long-term
agreements with so the clay stay for me
hormel they have bacon sponsor of course
with all that money there's always the
concern of losing creative license it's
not that we lost creative freedom but we
are definitely a little bit more censor
the internet is milking smart so on
television I mean you know there's a lot
more censorship involved but it also
means bigger budgets and more bacon the
first episode cost seventy dollars now
meals cost twenty thousand dollars on
the internet show we made meat cars once
which were cars like this big whereas on
Epic Meal Empire we made a full car that
I could drive and we ate it